every other night in Japan I step out of
my apartment I climb up a hill for 15
minutes and then I head into my local
health club where three ping pong tables
are set up in a studio and space is
limited so at every table one pair of
players practices four hands and other
practices backhands and every now and
then the balls collide in midair and
everybody says wow then choosing Lots we
select partners and play doubles
but I honestly couldn't tell you who is
one because we change partners every
five minutes and everybody is trying
really hard to win points but nobody is
keeping track of who is winning games
and after an hour or so a furious
exertion I can honestly tell you that
not knowing who's won feels like the
ultimate victory in Japan has been said
they've created a competitive spirit
without competition now all of you know
that geopolitics is best followed by
watching ping pong the two strongest
powers in the world were fiercest
enemies until in 1972 an American ping
pong team was allowed to visit communist
China and as soon as the former
adversaries were gathered around some
small green tables each of them could
claim a victory and the whole world
could breathe more easily China's leader
mud say Chung wrote a whole manual on
ping pong and he called the sport as
spiritual nuclear weapon and it's been
said that the only honoree lifelong
member of the US Table Tennis
Association is the then president
Richard Nixon who helped to engineer
this win-win situation through ping-pong
diplomacy but long before that
really the history of the modern world
was best told to the bouncing white ball
ping pong sounds like a cousin of
singsong like something Eastern but
actually it's believed that it was
invented by high-class Brits during
Victorian times who started hitting wine
corks over walls of books after dinner
no exaggeration and by the end of World
War one the sport was dominated by
players from the former austro-hungarian
Empire eight out of nine early World
Championships were claimed by Hungary
and Eastern Europeans grew so adept at
hitting back everything that was hit at
them so that they almost brought the
whole sport to a standstill in one
championship match in Prague in 1936 the
first point is said to have lasted two
hours and 12 minutes the first point
longer than a Mad Max movie and
according to one of the players the
umpire had to retire with a sore neck
before the point was include concluded
that player started hitting the ball
back with his left hand and dictating
chess moves between shots many in the
audience started of course filing out as
that single points lasted maybe 12,000
strokes and an emergency meeting of the
International Table Tennis Association
had to be held then and there and soon
the rules were changed so that no game
could last longer than 20 minutes
sixteen years later Japan entered the
picture when a little-known watchmaker
called hero-ji subtle showed up at the
World Championships in Bombay in 1952
and Sato is not very big he wasn't
highly rated he was wearing spectacles
but he was armed with a paddle that was
not pimpled as other paddles were but
covered by a thick spongy rubber foam
and thanks to this silencing secret
weapon the little-known Sato won a gold
medal 1 million people came out into the
streets of Tokyo to greet him upon his
return and really Japan's post-war
resurgence was set into motion what I
learned though at my regular games in
Japan is more what could be called the
inner sport of global domination as
sometimes known as life we never play
singles in our club only doubles and
because as I say we change partners
every 5 minutes if you do happen to lose
you're very likely to win 6 minutes
later we also play best of to sets so
often there's no loser at all ping-pong
diplomacy and I always remember that as
a boy growing up in England I was taught
that the point of a game was to win but
in Japan I'm encouraged to believe that
really the point of a game is to make as
many people as possible around you feel
that they are winners so you're not
cleaning up and down as an individual
might but you're part of a regular
steady chorus the most skillful players
in our club deploy their skills to turn
a 9 1 lead for their team into a 9 9
game in which everybody is intensely
involved
my friend who hits these high looping
lobs that smaller players flail at and
miss well he wins a lot of points but I
think he's thought of as a loser in
Japan a game of ping pong is really like
an act of love you're learning how to
play with somebody rather than against
her and I'll confess at first this
seemed to me to take all the fun out of
the sport
I couldn't exalt after a tremendous
upset victory against our strongest
players because six minutes later with a
new partner I was falling behind again
on the other hand I never felt
disconsolate and when I flew away from
Japan and started playing singles again
with my English archrival I noticed that
after every defeat I was really
brokenhearted but after every victory
I couldn't sleep either because I knew
there was only one way to go and that
was down now if I were trying to do
business in Japan this would lead to
endless frustration in Japan
unlike elsewhere if the score is still
level after four hours a baseball game
ends in a tie and because the league
standings are based on winning
percentage a team with quite a few ties
can finish ahead of a team with more
victories one of the first times an
American was ever brought over to Japan
to lead a professional Japanese baseball
team Bobby Valentine in 1995 he took
this really mediocre squad he led them
to a stunning second-place finish and he
was instantly fired why well said the
team spokesman because of his emphasis
on winning official Japan can feel quite
a lot like that points that were said to
last 2 hours and 12 minutes and playing
not to lose can take all the imagination
the daring the excitement out of things
at the same time playing ping-pong in
Japan reminds me why choirs regularly
enjoy more fun than soloists in a choir
your only job is to play your small part
perfectly to hit your notes with feeling
and by so doing to help to create a
beautiful harmony that's much greater
than the sum of its parts yes every
choir does need a conductor but I think
a choir releases you from a child's
simple sense of either all's you come to
see that the opposite of winning isn't
losing it's failing to see the larger
picture as my life goes on I'm really
startled to see that no event can
properly be assessed four years after it
has unfolded I once lost everything I
earn in the world every last thing in a
wildfire but in time I came to see that
it was that seeming loss that allowed me
to live on the earth more gently to
write without notes and actually to move
to Japan and the inner health club known
as the ping-pong table conversely I once
stumbled into the perfect job and I came
to see that seeming happiness can stand
in the way of true joy even more than
misery does playing doubles in Japan
really relieves me of all my anxiety and
at the end of an evening I notice
everybody is filing out in a more or
less equal state of delight I'm reminded
every night that not getting ahead isn't
the same thing
as falling behind any more than not
being lively is the same thing as being
dead and I've come to understand why it
is that Chinese universities are said to
offer degrees in ping pong and why
researchers have found that ping pong
can actually help a little with mild
mental disorders and even autism but as
I watched the 2020 Olympics in Tokyo I'm
going to be keenly aware that it won't
be possible to tell who's won or who's
lost for a very long time
you remember that point I mentioned was
said to last for 2 hours and 12 minutes
well one of the players from that game
ended up six years later in the
concentration camps of Auschwitz and
Dachau but he walked out alive why
simply because a guard in the gas
chamber recognized him from his ping
pong playing days
had he been the winner of that epic
match it hardly mattered as you recall
many people had filed out before even
the first point was concluded the only
thing that saved him was the fact that
he took part the best way to win any
game Japan tells me every other night is
never never to think about the score
thank you
you
[Music]